[Music]
being a financial expert in Parliament
opens a whole Vault of possibilities to
bring your talent to the cause of the
European democracy
[Music]
the European Parliament is the direct
elected representative of the people
with legislative budgetary and
supervisory power you will have the
chance to work in a very modern
environment which pays a lot of
attention to the work life balance and
you will be responsible for subjects
which are important to every European
citizen
Financial managers and accountants are
guaranteeing that the funds which
Parliament receives from taxpayers are
well used according to the rules and in
the most efficient way the procurement
experts are guaranteeing that the rules
are respected that there is no
Distortion of competition and that
Parliament receives the highest value
for the taxpayers money
[Music]
do not hesitate to participate in the
competition and me my team and other
colleagues in this institution will be
glad to welcome you with open arms as
our new colleagues